en una ceremonia llena de simbolismo
finalmente esta noche entro al panteón
la célebre necrópolis francesa donde
descansan los grandes hombres y mujeres
de este país la verde estadounidense de
nacionalidad francesa josephine baker la
ceremonia que duró más de una hora
repaso a través de esta avenida a la
avenida su flor cada una de las etapas
importantes de su vida su lucha contra
la discriminación racial cuando joven en
eeuu luego su lucha también por abrirse
un paso como cantante vedette actriz en
parís luego su compromiso con la
resistencia francesa la ocupación nazi
y compromiso también en la lucha por los
derechos civiles en eeuu y su idea de
crear una villa de la fraternidad
universal en el sur de francia adoptando
12 niños de nacionalidades y religiones
diferentes la ceremonia que terminó con
una marsellesa también fue cerrada por
un discurso del presidente manuel macrón
que recordó que josephine baker no luchó
por un color de piel sino por una idea
de la libertad por una idea del hombre
dijo su valor principal fue el
universalismo y dijo también que con el
ingreso al panteón de josephine baker
primera
artista
de escenario que entra a esta necrópolis
tan selecta entra un aire de audacia y
de libertad usted entra aquí porque amo
a francia usted es más francesa que
nunca dijo el presidente macro